hey what is going on YouTube now I know
a lot of you have already heard about
this but I felt that vlogging about this
topic would only be appropriate now
recently as I'm sure a lot of you guys
already know Robin Williams passed away
and to me he was one of the most
influential greatest comedian actors of
all time and when I found out the news
honestly it was a hard pill to swallow
actually when first hearing it I was in
disbelief and it was a really hard thing
to process because I didn't want to
believe what was being told to me but
when I allowed it to sink in I was
speechless now for those of you who
don't know as more and more information
is being brought out it's becoming more
apparent that the cause of death was
actually suicide now I understand that
this is a very large and heavy topic for
a lot of you to digest but it seems that
a lot of people out there don't
understand or can't grasp the concept of
a stand-up comedian or comedian in
general committing suicide now I know a
lot of you out there are thinking how
could a comedian who's light and art is
based on making other people happy take
his own life how could he not have been
happy himself not when you look at the
surface you only see the stuff that's
apparent you see the long successful
career that he's had the impact that
he's made but then you start to wonder
what was going on through his mind now I
know that this may come as a shock to a
lot of you out there but as a former
stand-up comedian and the current
entertainer yeah Robin Williams passing
was very shocking and surprising but at
the same time I'm not surprised that a
stand-up comedian would do something
like this I'm not saying I knew Robin
Williams on a personal level but what I
am saying is that I can tell you my
perception of comedy and comedians alike
I think a lot of people out there either
forget or you guys just are unaware of
the fact that a lot of the humor that
you relate to and listen to the root of
that comedy comes from a lot of pain and
personal experience you know I've said
this before but I think I'll say it
again comedy is real because it's an art
form that expresses laughter through
pain you know the stories that you hear
the [ __ ] up situation that we've been
in and all the humor that comes from
that comes from a very personal space
it's just that comedians had this
ability to take that anguish and turn it
into something parable which for us is
laughter when I was younger at an early
age I found out that a lot of
times when I was going through a lot of
[ __ ] all I could do was laugh at the
situation and when I did that it just it
took away all the pain you know one of
the reasons why I even became a stand-up
comic in the first place was because I
found out about the power that laughter
had and I wanted to share it
how laughter had a healing property and
it could change a situation by a simple
foot in perception you know in my case
when I was a stand-up comedian I used to
go onstage and grab a mic and I used to
just bust people up laughing and they
would be in tears that was the greatest
joy for me and the reason why was
because I was allowed to share my
personal stories in pain take that and
make them laugh do it it was it was
therapeutic it kind of helped me deal
with my problems but at the same time it
brought other people joy it was it was a
win-win situation and doing that gave me
purpose in the Robin Williams case I
can't help but wonder if at the moment
of his death that he realized how much
his work affected everybody else in the
world and if he didn't and that was the
case how lonely must he have been a lot
of you might not understand this but to
be a comedian that could give life and
value to other people through the comedy
that you make but to not be able to do
that for yourself you know that must
have been terrifying to be honest when
the laughter stops and you can't find
joy through that pain that is exactly
what you're left with pain I can't speak
for other comedians but when I can't
find the joy and laughter and what I do
I don't know what my purpose on this
planet would be I would be lost I
wouldn't know what to do and once again
for those of you out there who aren't
comedians or don't really understand the
comic world I want you to really think
about why you were late to a lot of
these comics who talk about their
personal stories why does it hit so hard
for you at home why does it make you
laugh so much the comedy is real because
the emotion and paint behind the
laughter is real and what you can't
understand that you're not going to be
able to fully grasp the gravity of the
situation even for me I I can't grasp
the whole situation but what I can tell
you as an aspiring actor writer comedian
is that we lost someone very special
that day and Robin I genuinely hope
that you understand how important you
were to a lot of people out there rest
in peace